bonjour eric zemmour bonjour on se
souvient qu emmanuel macron avait promis
d'instaurer une dose de proportionnelle
pour les prochaines législatives
est-ce qu'il doit tenir cet engagement
écoutez déjà l'expression dose propose
de proportionnelle ça ramène les plus
vieux d'entre nous à françois mitterrand
en 1985 qui avait déjà parlé de dose de
proportionnelle
avant de se résoudre à une
proportionnelle intégrale vous voyez
quand il ya le mot dos ça veut dire que
tu auras la proportionnelle intégrale
parce qu'en fait la dose comme on dit
demande des choses très compliquées et
demanda redécoupage des circonscriptions
et comme on le fait toujours au dernier
moment on n'a jamais le temps de le
faire et donc ça règle en oublions ce
côté technique et allons essayons de 20
sur les principes la proportionnelle a
priori est contraire à la 5ème
république c'est à dire qu'on a la 5ème
république est liée au scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours pourquoi parce
que justement michel debré et le général
de gaulle voulait contenir les abus du
régime d'assemblée de la quatrième
république qui était régi par la
proportionnelle et qui multipliait les
groupes l'ailé les parties etc et dans
un désordre y avait plus de majorité
pour gouverner voyez ça c'est c'est
vraiment l'esprit de sa gamme implique
des bd des commencements évidemment on a
une image des modes de scrutin les modes
de scrutin c'est fondamental dans sa
déterminent la vie politique d'un pays
le plus le plus le plus évident le plus
connu c'est le fameux mode de scrutin à
un tour des anglais qui donne le régime
bipartisans anglais les conservateurs
contre les travaillistes et en allant
pralong comment dire allons vers la
proportionnelle aujourd'hui oublions la
4ème république
mais la proportion aujourd'hui ça donne
des régimes ingouvernable ça donne
israël ça donne même l'italie enfin
voyez c'est bon pourtant la
proportionnelle c'est la promesse d'une
représentation plus juste de la réalité
politique du pays non et c'est une
discussion depuis deux siècles on a le
scrutin majoritaire qui permet de
gouverner la proportionnelle qui est
plus juste parce que tout le monde est
représenté
mais même cette dichotomie là qu'on a
tous appris à sciences po etc et désuète
parce que je vous donne deux exemples
l'allemagne un régime proportion un
scrutin proportionnel
tout le monde est bien représentée et il
ya une stabilité parce que dans les
institutions ça ils ont organisé ça pour
les les garder quand même une stabilité
en vérité aujourd'hui si vous voulez la
proportionnelle c'était bien pour
compenser le désordre d'avant de la 4ème
république aujourd'hui dans un système
qui a complètement chamboulé qui était
chamboulé avec l'élection du présent à
public au suffrage universel
le parlementarisme rationalisé les le
quinquennat et surtout le renversement
du calendrier vous vous souvenez c'est à
dire que les législatives sont après la
présidentielle
ça fait que le parlement est devenu une
coquille vide et donc là il faut
effectivement comme vous dites
retrouvez une représentation
démocratique pour parler clairement il
n'est pas normal que le front national
rassemblement national comme on veut
n'est qu'une poignée de députés alors
que sa candidate fait 20% ou 25% la
présidentielle ce n'est pas raisonnable
d ce n'est pas démocratique donc et il
faut effectivement et je vous dis en
plus aujourd'hui
là le scrutin majoritaire est devenu une
arme en trop inquiets alors que c'était
bien pour compenser le désordre c'est
devenu excessif pour mettre encore plus
d'ordre voyez c'est pas possible
pour vous le problème ce n'est pas le
mode de scrutin le sujet est plus
profond on a changé de monde c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui les démocraties
nationales sont gouvernées par en tout
cas en europe par la commission de
bruxelles et ses fameuses directive
auquel les gouvernements doivent se
soumettre et les juges qui au nom de
l'état de droit
interprète la déclaration des droits de
l'homme transforme des principes
philosophiques en principe juridique et
donc en vérité font la loi à la place du
législateur
donc si vous voulez on dit la
proportionnelle serait bien pour une
représentation démocratique de tous les
courants de pensée
on a raison mais ça ne changerait pas ça
c'est à dire que de toute façon même un
parlement plus représentatif ne serait
pas n'aurait pas plus de pouvoir et il
serait quand même dirigé par les juges
et parler comme ici la commission de
bruxelles c'est à dire que la démocratie
parlementaire aurait repris des couleurs
mais elle serait toujours gouverné par
une oligarchie
d'ici là et technocratique donc ça ne
changerait rien simplement ça donnerait
un peu de vie un peu de couleurs au
théâtre d'ombrés de la démocratie
nationale
merci eric zemmour